when you get through this question your
listing factors right we're looking for
numbers that I can divide by and have no
remainders out right that's what a
factor is like what kind of groups can I
split 24 into okay
now you can always stop my saying 1
because every number can give you the
bottom of 1 and then you start going
through the numbers and dividing through
mentally ahead and can I divide through
without a remainder
now one of the questions people ask me
is how do I know I've got all the
factors like do I have to check every
single number and there's a way it
almost rates really cool how you can
know you've got all the factors okay
watch very closely
you start with 1 right it's an even
number so that means I can divide by 2
right that's another even number there
so just go to and you start to go
through I can divide by 3 and I can
divide by 4 and then we're going to
pause right when I get to the next
number 5 that doesn't define but 6 does
not pause I'm gonna write 6 here instead
of continuing on and the reason why I
write 6 then is because what is 24
divided by 6 is 24 divided by 6 it's
it's 4 is it it's 4 and 4 is a number
that's already on my list do you see
that I already knew that so what happens
is it 4 & 6 are in fact matched up
together they repaired right like that
every factor has a pair in a number okay
as I keep going I'm going to go
backwards and I'm gonna pair up the
other numbers 7 doesn't divide through
what it does right what's 8 divided -
it's gonna be 3 so you see I've got
another pair yeah
now having done that is quite a few
numbers I've got to go through to get to
the next number but I can work it out
rather than do it every single one
visually I just look for then they
expand what's 24/2 it's 12
that's the next pair like that and now
you can see I'm only got without having
tested every single one remember
mathematicians lazy trying to minimize
the work that we do I know there's only
one more number that's going to go in my
life my list what is it 24 because it
matches with one okay I don't need to
test that 17 18 19 20 21 etcetera I
already know I've got my complete list
there cuz everything matches hard so
when you're going through the factors
rather just list them out yeah I got all
the way through I would encourage you to
try and pair them up okay now just one
more thing I want to show you the next
number 25 this is an interesting one
because we can start with one not even
doesn't have three or four the next one
is five
okay but five so videos you see what
happens when you divide 25 by 5 what do
you get back with you you get back that
number so I found 5 is kind of its own
pair right there's nothing else paired
up with it so in fact after that the
only number left is 25 right so these
guys care up and this guy he kinda just
hangs out with himself is he's a fun guy
ok so you can see some of the numbers
are it's sneaky like that and there's
special numbers when you go through and
you do the sieve of eratosthenes that's
how you pronounce it by the way see
above I provide right along is toss
don't ask me what tossing these means
but that's how you pronounce his name
crazy Greeks okay when you look at when
you look at question 5 and you grab your
sum is sheet from me and you go through
the sieve of eratosthenes you will see
you will get all the primes their own
competence there and you'll notice these
ones are special okay so I'll let you
discover that in